je pense en tout cas qu'il faut éviter
une chose absolue c'est leur confinement
je vais vous dire que ça traîne aussi
dans les discours on l'entend parfois
moi je vois ce qui s'est passé lorsqu'on
a reconçu confiner la première fois vous
avez des personnes seules qui se sont
retrouvés complètement isolés qui sont
mises en danger
pas forcément que des personnes âgées
d'ailleurs il ya il ya un coût social
qui va être terrible donc il faut à tout
crin en tout cas éviter en confinement
prendre des mesures c'est nécessaire à
condition de pas cibler une profession
plutôt qu'une autre
je trouve que la population est
extraordinairement discipline et enfin
on a les gens portent le masque
j'ai pris un arrêté sur le port du
masque dès la fin du mois d'août pour
être vraiment en amont en tout cas dans
les zones où il y avait potentiellement
plus de monde et zones commerçantes du
centre-ville
c'est très bien respectée honnêtement si
on était assez café moi je trouve que
les patrons font leur boulot là quand
même
disons le clairement depuis des mois sur
une absence complète de cap on va à
droite on va à gauche on revient en
arrière et ça je pense que même si la
situation n'est pas simple à gérer je
l'entends parfaitement du côté du
gouvernement
pour autant aujourd'hui quels sont les
français dans leur ville dans leurs
départements qui sont capables de dire
avec certitude ce qu'ils ont droit de
faire et ne pas faire
le message a été complètement brouillé
par absence de cap et finalement on met
les gens en danger parce qu'il ya une
incertitude généralisée sur les mesures
à prendre je pense qu'il ya une illusion
monsieur macron est un hypnotiseur et il
a hypnotisé une partie de la classe
politique
ah oui quand vous déconstruisent et son
discours j'ai passé mon week-end non pas
avec monsieur macro mais en tout cas
avec le texte de monsieur macron sûr
intéressant de regarder le texte et pas
simplement de regarder les images à la
télé parce que vous ne retenez à avec
les yeux quand vous êtes sur un écran
qu'une partie de ce qui est dit il
rassure tout le monde avec des mesures
assez emblématique
on va interdire les menus confessionnels
dans certaines communes c'est à dire les
menus halal disons disons le comme elles
sont on va interdire que les piscines
soit réservé à certains créneaux
horaires aux seules femmes etc etc
donc ça c'est la partie rassurante et
puis à la quatrième partie du discours
qui en fait rien moins que l'adaptation
la république à une religion qui
s'appelle l'islam il veut promouvoir
l'enseignement de l'arabe dans l'école
il veut que par délégation de service
public le conseil français du culte
musulman certifie les imams sur le
territoire enfin on est en train de
complètement mettre sous le tapis
la loi de 1905 sur la laïcité qui
interdisait à l'état de toucher à leur
religion
monsieur macron dit m
il essaye de s'en défendre mais c'est
très clair dans son discours monsieur
macron dit il faut que les cartes
organisé ce n'est pas son boulot mais le
principe de la laïcité ça n'est pas
d'organiser les religions à leur place
c'est d'être une digue contre
l'empiètement de la religion sur
l'espace public ce n'est pas parce que
vous voter une loi à grand renfort de
médiatisation que vous régler le
problème
aujourd'hui le salafisme l'islamisme est
en train de progresser dans nos
quartiers et ce ne sont pas ces mesures
qui l'empêcheront vous allumiez que le
projecteur sur un des grandes faiblesses
de ce texte est à dire en gros monsieur
macro ont fait des choix
il interdit certaines choses mais pas
d'autres les accompagnatrices scolaires
pourront toujours être voilées alors
qu'eux ils elles accomplissent une
mission de service public et que l amène
un signe religieux dans l'école où adam
la perdre la sortie périscolaire qui
dépendrait de la pédagogie
les étudiants pourront continuer d'être
voilée à l'université en assemblée ce
qui est salafistes est ce que monsieur
macron nous a dit qu'il allait fermer
non on à 3400 étrangers convaincu de
radicalisation est ce qu il a dit qu'il
allait les expulser non on pourrait
multiplier les choses comme ça donc en
fait on a fait du cosmétique s'appelait
une partie de la classe politique
visiblement il a réussi son but et ça ne
réglera pas le problème de laisser la
place aux convois bien qu'il a fait des
choix et ses choix sont là pour essayer
de rassurer une partie de l'électorat
mais je le dis dès maintenant et je me
permets de le dire avec certitude sur la
base des anciennes lois qu'on a voté qui
n'ont pas toutes été appliquée ça ne
réglera pas la question de l'islamisme
en france on a fait de l'habillage et il
le faut il faut ouvrir les yeux sur la
réalité ça ne sera pas suffisant pour
empêcher des progressions qui ne font
qu'augmenter depuis 40 ans et il ya
quelque chose qui me choque profondément
ouais moi je respecte le législateur il
fait généralement un travail fabuleux
notamment mes amis dans le républicain
dans l'opposition pour autant on n'a
jamais consulté le peuple français sur
ce changement de société
depuis que la droite a institué le
regroupement familial dans les années 70
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
concernant l'immigration l'intégration
ou l'absence assimilation ne sont jamais
passés devant le peuple français il
serait bon qu'à un moment donné sur ces
questions qui sont des changements de
société
bref on consulte la france